♪
>> Laura: I'M JASON CHANGE FITS
IN FOR LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS
IS A SPECIAL EDITION OF THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT A SHAMELESS
DC IT USUALLY REFERS TO THE
GRIFT AND GRIDLOCK THAT
POPULATES THE HALLS OF CONGRESS
AND LOBBYING SHOPS.
BUT NOW DC MAYOR MURIEL BOWSER
IS GETTING IN ON THE ACTION AND
BEGGING THE NATIONAL GUARD FOR
HELP DEALING WITH THE INFLUX OF
ILLEGALS COMING INTO THE CITY.
WHICH SEEMS PRETTY HYPOCRITICAL
COMING FROM SOMEONE WHO DECLARED
THIS BACK WHEN TRUMP WAS BEING
INAUGURATED.
>> I CAN'T SAY IT ANYMORE
CLEARLY OF WHAT IT MEANS FOR
WASHINGTON, DC TO BE A SANK
TAKER CITY AND BE SHIRE THAT
PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE FEEL FREE
TO CALL ON THEIR GOVERNMENT FOR
HELP.
>> AND CALL ON THE GOVERNMENT
DOR HELP SHE DID.
RED STRAIGHT GOVERNORS LIKE
ABBOTT IN TEXAS AND DOOZY IN
ARIZONA HAVE BEEN SENDING
ILLEGALS TO OUR NATION'S CAPITOL
BY BUS FOR THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
SOME EVEN ARRIVED AS RECENTLY AS
THIS MORNING.
THIS IS A VERY SMALL, LITTLE,
TINY PORTION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 4,000 PEOPLE
OUT OF MILLIONS WHO HAVE CROSSED
OUR BORDER.
AND NOW THAT BOWSER IS SEEING
WHAT BORDER STATES HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH SINCE BIDEN AND
HARRIS CAME INTO OFFICE, IT'S
"NOT IN MY BACKYARD."
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE OF
COURSE IS JUMPING ALL OVER THIS
SAYING, QUOTE, THE SECRETARY
TAKES THIS REQUEST FOR
ASSISTANCE VERY SERIOUSLY.
THE QUESTION NOW BECOMES, IF
IT'S SO EASY FOR BOWSER TO CALL
IN THE NATIONAL GUARD AND GET
LEGITIMATE, IMMEDIATE RESPONSE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE,
WHY AREN'T OTHER STATES DOING
EXACTLY THE SAME THING?
THIS WAS THE GIST OF A TRULY
REMARKABLE BACK AND FORTH AT THE
WHITE HOUSE YESTERDAY THAT
SPEAKS TO THE GREATER ISSUE
HERE.
WATCH THIS.
>> PRESIDENT GOING TO APPROVE
THAT REQUEST FOR THE NATIONAL
GUARD?
>> WE HAVE BEEN IN REGULAR TOUCH
WITH MAYOR BOWSER AND HER TEAM.
AND I SAID THIS BEFORE, I SAID
THIS LAST WEEK ABOUT REPUBLICANS
USING MIGRANTS AS A POLITICAL
TOOL, AND THAT IS SHAMEFUL AND
THAT IS JUST WRONG.
>> SO THE WHITE HOUSE'S
PREFERENCE WOULD BE FOR SMALL
TOWNS IN TEXAS AND ARIZONA TO
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THESE
MIGRANTS RATHER THAN A LARGE
METROPOLITAN CITY LIKE
WASHINGTON, DC.
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT I SAID.
>> THAT IS WHAT YOU SAID.
>> THAT IS NOT.
I SAID THAT THERE IS -- WE ARE.
THEY'RE SENDING MIGRANTS TO BIG
CITIES ON PURPOSES AS A
POLITICAL PLOY.
>> IF THEY DON'T GO TO BIG
CITIES.
>> THERE'S A PROCESS I JUST LAID
IT OUT.
>> THE MAYOR SAYS SHE NEEDS THE
NATIONAL GUARD?
>> THAT'S BECAUSE REPUBLICANS
ARE USING, THEY'RE USING
MIGRANTS, WHO ARE COMING HERE
FOR WHO KNOWS, BECAUSE THEY
ARE -- THEY'RE DEALING WITH
HUMANITARIAN ISSUES BACK IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
THEY'RE COMING HERE FOR A BETTER
LIFE AND THEY ARE BEING USED,
PETER, THEY'RE BEING USED BY
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS.
THAT IS WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> DOES ANY OF THIS MAKE THE
PRESIDENT WANT TO SAY, THIS IS
CAUSING A LOT OF BURDENS ON
SMALL CITIES, BIG CITIES MAYBE I
SHOULD CLOSE THE BOARDRS.
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS WHAT
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING IS WRONG
AND THERE IS A PROCESS IN PLACE
AND WE SHOULD FOLLOW THE
PROCESS.
>> WOW.
JOINING ME NOW IS NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN AND GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE LEE ZELDEN.
THANK YOU I HAD THE PLEASURE
SERVING WITH YOU.
LET'S GO TO CONGRESSMAN ROY
FIRST, THE HYPOCRISY HERE IT'S
TRIPPING WITH HYPOCRISY.
WHAT'S YOUR REEKS TO WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING?
>> OH, MY GOSH, I COULD SIT HERE
ALL NIGHT LONG.
GREAT TO BE HERE WITH MY FRIEND
LEE AND GREAT CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK AND I'M
PROUD TO SERVE WITH HIM.
LET ME JUST SAY SOMETHING.
LISTENING TO HER TALK ABOUT
REPUBLICANS ARE USING THESE
MIGRANTS IS OFFENSIVE.
IT'S DEMOCRATS USING THESE
MIGRANTS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
IT'S CARTELS USING THESE
MIGRANTS.
BECAUSE WHILE THE NEWS IS
FOCUSED AND FIXATE ORDER MAYOR
BOWSER COMPLAINING ABOUT 4,000
MIGRANTS COMING TO DC BECAUSE
GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAID HEY WE'RE
GOING TO PUT SOME BUS LOADS AND
TAKE THEM TO DC, WHEN WE GET
4,000 A DAY, THERE WERE 73 HUMAN
BEINGS FOUND IN A STASH HOUSE IN
WASHINGTON, DC, IN A STASH
HOUSE, WHERE THEY GET PUT INTO
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING TRADE
BECAUSE WE'RE ALLOWING CARTELS
TO MOVE THESE HUMAN BEINGS FOR
PROFIT IN THE FALSE NAME OF
COMPASSION WHILE MY DEMOCRAT
COLLEAGUES PAT THEMSELVES ON THE
BACK AND MEANWHILE THESE PEOPLE
ARE PUT INTO THIS RIDICULOUS
TRADE FOR PROFIT FOR CARTELS.
I CAN'T EVEN PUT IT INTO WORDS.
AND TO LISTEN TO THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SAY WE'RE USING
THEM?
THEY ARE THE ONES USING THEM.
LET ME TELL YOU THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN SOUTH TEXAS WHO ARE SICK OF
IT, THAT'S WHY WE'RE SEEING
FLORES DO WELL AND WHY WE'RE
SEEING A BIG CHANGE IN THE
POLITICS IN SOUTH TEXAS AND IT'S
A SHAME MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES
WANT TO USE THEM FOR POLITICS.
>> YEAH, NO, IT IS.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE THEY
WOULD COME TO THAT CONCLUSION.
CONGRESSMAN  ZELDEN HAS BEEN
SENDING THEM TO NEW YORK FOR
MONTHS, CONGRESSMAN FLORES
CONFRONTED THE WHITE HOUSE ABOUT
IT TODAY.
LISTEN.
>> WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TEXAS BUSSING THEM TO DC AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FLYING THEM
TO NEW YORK.
>> IT'S VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT DOING IT USING THEM AS
A POLITICAL PAWN.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
>> FIRST OFF WE HAVE TO SHUT
DOWN THAT TRAVEL AGENT THAT'S
FLYING PEOPLE INTO NEW YORK AND
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE FLYING
PEOPLE INTO NEW YORK IN THE DEAD
OF NIGHT AND THERE'S THAT LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY REALLY SHOWS YOU
A LOT ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH HERE BEHIND THE
SCENES.
IF THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WERE PROUD OF, THEN THEY WOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT THESE FLIGHTS
AND THERE WOULD BE DATA OF HOW
MANY FLIGHTS WERE COMING, THERE
WOULD BE A HEADS UP THAT THEY
WERE COMING.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO STAND BY
THAT TRAVEL AGENCY.
AS FAR AS WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE
BORDER, THAT REALLY ULTIMATELY
IS THE WAY THAT THIS WHOLE ISSUE
GETS RESOLVED, IT'S FINISHING
CONSTRUCTION OF THE BORDER WALL,
IT'S ENDING CATCH AND RELEASE
ENFORCING THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
AND SUPPORTING OUR BORDER PATROL
AGENTS ON TOP OF SUBJECTING DOWN
THE TRAVEL AGENCY THAT IS
SENDING PEOPLE TO NEW YORK IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
>> CONGRESSMAN ROY, SHOULDN'T
MURIEL BOWSER BE CALLING ICE OR
MAYBE THE BORDER PATROL?
ISN'T THAT THE WAY TO DEAL WITH
THIS?
>> YEAH, YOU WOULD THINK.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
THAT MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES,
AND PARTICULARLY THE BIDEN
DISCIPLINERATION AND IN
PARTICULAR SECRETARY MAYORKAS
WHO LIED TO ME AND EVERY MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND ALL OF AMERICA WHEN HE SAID
THAT THEY HAVE OPERATIONAL
CONTROL OF THE BORDER, WHICH IS
A BLATANT LIE.
WE COULD SOLVE THIS PROBLEM WITH
POLICY CHANGES TOMORROW.
I WENT TO EAGLE PASS TEXAS THREE
WEEKS AGO TO A PROCESSING
FACILITY.
LET ME EXPLAIN TO AMERICA,
THEY'RE BRINGING PEOPLE INTO A
PROCESSING FACILITY, THEY'RE
THEN PROCESSING THEM AND
RELEASING THEM INTO THE UNITED
STATES UNDER NOTICE TO APPEAR OR
PAROLE.
NOT EVEN ASYLUM CLAIM
PROCESSING.
THE ONLY BARRIER IS THE USE OF
TITLE 42 AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO GET RID
OF THAT, THE TITLE 42 POLICIES
UNDER COVID.
IT'S ABSURD, A COMPLETE
VIOLATION OF OUR LAWS AND
FRANKLY SECRETARY MAYORKAS
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED FOR IT AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN ADDRESS THAT
NEXT YEAR.
>> CONGRESSMAN PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS CALLED SEEN PHOBIC TO PUT UP
THE BOARDER WALL BUT BIDEN WHO
PLEDGED TO NOT PUT ANOTHER FOOT
OF WALL IN PLACE IS GOING TO
BUILD THE WALL IN YUMA.
ROY, WHAT'S THE PLAY HERE?
>> THE RIGHT CALL, THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE ON THE MERIT, IT
WOULD BE TO FINISH CONSTRUCTION
OF THE BORDER WALL.
AND TO SEE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
SPENDING TO NOT BUILD THIS WALL.
AND THEN YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
UTILIZING THIS ISSUE WITH
REGARDS TO POLITICAL PAWNS, IT
WAS THIS ADMINISTRATION THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW THAT WAS GOING
AFTER OUR OWN CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL AND ACCUSING THEM OF
WHIPPING PEOPLE COMING ACROSS,
AND THEN THE MEDIA RUNNING WITH
IT.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE'RE SEEING THE
STORIES NOW, AS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE DC MAYOR, IN NEW YORK
CITY YOU HAD THE MAYOR TALKING
ABOUT HOW THE SHELTERS WERE
BEING OVERRUN.
AND YOU THINK THAT YOU HAVE IT
BAD?
THINK ABOUT BEING THE GOVERNOR
RIGHT NOW OF TEXAS, OR BEING THE
GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA.
THEY HAVE IT A THOUSAND TIMES
WORSE.
WHAT WE ALL SHOULD BE DOING IS
THAT EVERY LEVEL WORKING
TOGETHER BUT THIS PUSH TOWARD
SANCTUARY STATE AND SANCTUARY
CITY POLICIES AND THIS BLAME
GAME AND SPIN WITH AN ELECTION
COMING UP IS RESULTING IN MORE
PEOPLE BEING INCENTIVIZED AND
REWARDED TO COME ACROSS.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE UNTIL WE
CONFRONT THIS.
>> CLEARLY IT'S HUMAN AND DRUG
TRAFFICKING BUT THANK GOODNESS
WE